we're now going to explore hypothesis
testing when we're thinking about the
difference between proportions of two
different populations so here it says
here are the results from a recent poll
that involved sampling voters from each
of two neighboring districts district a
and district B and folks were asked
whether they support a new law or not
and from each district we took a sample
of 100 voters and then we were able to
calculate the proportion from that
sample that supported the law and then
here we have the combined data including
the combined proportion and we're asked
does this suggest a significant
difference between the two districts and
so this is asking for a hypothesis test
and the way we would do that is we would
set up our null hypothesis and remember
our null hypothesis is the one that we
would assume that there is no difference
so we would assume that the true
proportion of folks in district a that
support the new law is equal to the
proportion in district B that support
the law or another way to think about it
is that the difference would be equal to
zero and our alternative hypothesis is
that the absolute difference between the
proportions is not equal to zero and if
we were doing an all-out hypothesis test
we would set a significance level which
we usually denote with an alpha
oftentimes it might be a 10 percent
significance level or a 5 percent
significance level let's say we set it
at a 5 percent significance level and
what we would do is we would say all
right let's assume that the null
hypothesis is true and assuming the null
hypothesis is true what is the
probability of getting a difference
between our sample proportions this
extreme or more and if that probability
is less than our significance level then
we reject the null hypothesis
which would suggest the alternative now
before we go deeper into our inference
we want to test our conditions for
inference and we've seen these many
times before you have the random
condition where you would need to feel
good that both of these samples are
truly random you would have your normal
condition which is that you would have
at least 10 successes and failures in
each of these samples and we see that we
do in
have at least 10 successes and at least
10 failures in each of those samples and
then you have your independence
condition and the independence condition
you're either sampling with replacement
or you need to feel good that each of
these sample sizes are no more than 10%
of the entire population and so I guess
we will assume that there's at least a
thousand folks in district a and at
least a thousand folks in district B and
that will allow us to meet the
independence condition and so with that
out of the way let's assume the null
hypothesis and let's just start thinking
about the sampling distribution of the
difference between the sample
proportions assuming that null
hypothesis so the first thing I want to
think about is what is going to be the
standard deviation of the difference in
the sampling distributions well we have
seen in a previous video when we talked
about differences of proportions we
could think about the variance so the
variance of the sampling distribution
there's a lot of notation here so the
variance this is going to be equal to
the variance of the sampling
distribution of the sample proportion
from district A plus the variance of the
sampling distribution of the sample
proportion from district B now in
general you can figure out the variance
of the sampling distribution of a sample
proportion with the following formula
we've seen this before the variance of
the sampling distribution of the sample
proportion is going to be equal to our
true proportion times 1 minus our true
proportion all of that over your sample
size now in either situation we don't
know the true proportions for district a
or district B that's why we are in this
one that's why we're even doing this
hypothesis test to begin with but we can
try to estimate it remember we're
assuming that the true proportions are
equal even though we might not know what
they are and what is going to be our
best estimate of that true proportion if
we assume that district a and district B
have no difference in terms of the
number
to support the new law well the best
estimate would actually be the combined
sample the combined sample proportion
right over here and so to estimate these
values we use this combined sample
proportion in the place of P over here
so we could say that this is going to be
our combined sample proportion times 1
minus our combined sample proportion all
of that over our sample size and since
we're assuming that there's no
difference between district a and
district B this would also apply to that
right over there so let me rewrite this
again the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the difference
of the sample proportions from district
a and district B is going to be roughly
remember we weren't able to calculate it
exactly but we're using this combined
proportion as our best estimate let me
do a big square root right over here big
radical and so underneath that we are
going to have our estimate of this which
is 0.55 times 1 minus 0.55 so 0.45 over
100 plus our estimate of this which is
0.55 it's the same thing again is times
0.45 and remember that's because we're
assuming the null hypothesis is true all
of that over this sample size all of
that over 100 and now we can get our
calculator out to actually calculate it
and so we get the square root of 0.55
times 0.45 divided by 100 now I could
add that whole thing again or I could
just multiply by 2 so times 2 is equal
to approximately zero point zero seven
so this is going to be approximately
equal to zero point zero seven and now
using this we can calculate a z-score
and then we could think about what's the
probability of getting a z-score that
extreme
or more and so our z-score or our Z
value would be equal to the difference
that we got P sub P hat sub a minus P
hat sub B all of that over our estimate
of the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of this difference
between the sample proportions so all of
that over zero point zero seven now this
up here in yellow it's zero point five
eight minus is zero point 5 2 this is
going to be equal to zero point zero six
over zero point zero seven zero point
zero seven we can get our calculator out
for this again and so we have Oh point
zero six divided by 0.07 it is going to
be its approximately 0.86 so this is
approximately zero point eight six now
what's the probability of getting
something this extreme or more extreme
let me just make sure we can visualize
it properly so if this is our sampling
distribution of the difference between
our sample proportions and we're
assuming the null hypothesis so the mean
of our sampling distribution is going to
be zero is going to be zero right there
we just got a result that is less than a
standard deviation above the mean so we
just got a result so if this is 1
standard deviation two standard
deviations above the mean one standard
deviation below the mean two standard
deviations below the mean we just got a
result that is that puts us right there
and if we ask ourselves what's the
probability of getting a result at least
that extreme we would say okay it would
be what's the probably getting a result
all of this area right over here and it
would also be what's this area on the
other side of the mean and we know that
this is over 30% because even if you
just exclude one standard deviation
above and below the mean if you say
anything more extreme than that so if
you put this area and this area you're
thinking you're looking at roughly 31 or
32 percent so the probability of getting
something at least this extreme is going
to be over 30% and so it's definitely
going to be higher than our significance
level it's actually completely
reasonable to get a difference
this extreme if we assume the null
hypothesis is true in future videos we
can go even deeper where we can actually
just look this up on AZ table to
calculate these areas more precisely and
we can compare them to the significance
level but here it's not even close we're
nowhere close to being able to reject
the null hypothesis so to answer the
question does this suggest a significant
difference between the two districts no
no it doesn't